[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
vaughn crime network is in the courtroom
for day one of gelane maxwell's trial we
bring you the latest from federal court
and cell phone video captures the
shooting death of a texas man but wasn't
murder or self-defense plus elizabeth
holmes takes the stand in her own
defense why the theranos ceo says she
used pharmaceutical company logos
without permission and later opening
statements begin in new hampshire where
a man is accused of killing his wife for
a life insurance payout law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin a jury is seated and opening
statements have begun in the highly
anticipated trial of gilain maxwell the
one-time socialite faces multiple
charges stemming from a relationship
with a long-time companion and financial
heavyweight jeffrey epstein the 59 year
old is charged with conspiracy to entice
minors to engage in illegal sex acts and
transportation of a minor to engage in
an illegal sex act federal prosecutors
say maxwell helped epstein groom girls
as young as 14 for sexual abuse and
sometimes participated in opening
statements prosecutors said maxwell was
a predator who quote helped normalize
abusive sexual conduct and served up
girls to epstein maxwell's defense team
said in its opening statement the memory
of victims have been contaminated by
faded memories and media reports and
called maxwell a scapegoat for epstein
in 2019 epstein was arrested on federal
charges of sex trafficking just months
after his arrest epstein was found dead
by suicide maxwell pled not guilty to
all charges
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and terry
austin bernarda faded memories and
maxwell as a scapegoat comment on the
strength of the defense's opening
statement so far
so the defense attorney in the opening
statement was opening for about an hour
long her focus in the opening statement
was to put out this theme this narrative
that all these women that are coming in
to testify these four complainants that
they are in it for the money in fact she
detailed how each one of these four got
an enormous amount of money and even got
more money because they cooperated with
the government i believe one of the jane
doles actually got five million another
jane doe got 3.5 million there's a jane
though that aside from money she is
seeking assistance from the government
to help her gain citizenship here in the
united states but the whole focus of the
opening statement is to try to kill the
credibility the believability of the
alleged complainants in this indictment
because according to the defense there
is no corroboration there are no
eyewitnesses there are no video so
there's nothing to corroborate their
fated memories
interesting concept for the defense
there now terry you've reviewed the
indictment in this case how difficult do
you think it will be for the prosecution
to prove these charges
you know brian this is not going to be a
slam dunk for the prosecution there are
six counts four victims there's the
conspiracy to entice miners to travel
and then actually enticing them to
travel the conspiracy to transport the
miners and then actually transporting
those miners and what they have to show
here is that galaine maxwell herself
nothing to do with jeffrey epstein but
she herself recruited and groomed those
minor victims and so it's going to be
probably
corroborated with forensic evidence
you're going to have to show that she
made phone calls she booked those travel
tickets not just that she was involved
but she was intimately involved and i
think if they can do that and they can
bolster that with the
alleged victim's testimony interesting
there's definitely a lot of smoke in
this case i guess for the prosecution
i've got to prove that where there's
smoke there's also fire we'll see how
that plays out
looking ahead jury selection begins
tuesday in the trial of former minnesota
police officer kim potter charged in the
shooting death of donte wright
potter faces first and second degree
manslaughter charges last april police
were trying to take wright a 20-year-old
black man into custody when potter
pulled her gun and shot him in the chest
potter claimed she meant to pull a taser
instead of the gun wright died his death
caused unrest across brooklyn center
minnesota and into minneapolis the
minnesota governor later declared a
state of emergency potter and then
brooklyn center police chief tim gannon
resigned from their positions days after
the shooting the law and crime network
will bring you gavital gavel coverage of
the trial beginning with jury selection
opening statements are set for december
8.
still ahead on law and crime daily the
prosecution arrests after nearly 30
witnesses now disgraced ceo elizabeth
holmes takes a stand in her own defense
as she fights charges of wire fraud but
first confrontation caught on camera
cell phone video shows the moments
before a man was shot to death during a
clash over child presentation all that
and more after this
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
attorney general's office in texas is
investigating the shooting death of a
man during a confrontation over child
visitation the whole thing was caught on
camera law and crime's angina levy is
here with the video
brian kyle carruth shot and killed chad
redd on november 5th in lubbock county
and we want to warn you some people may
find the following video disturbing now
the confrontation was at kyle karuth's
home he is the man in the black shirt
chad red is the man in the aqua colored
shirt red went to the home to pick up
his son for a visit and a confrontation
between red and carruth ensued carruth
is the boyfriend of red's ex who can
also be seen in the video red's wife
jennifer recorded what happened on her
cell phone
[Music]
i have it on video kyle you did it and i
told you
i told all of y'all to lean
we came to get hurt his son
she should have told that
she should have told that
now the district attorney in lubbock
county texas actually asked the texas
attorney general's office to handle this
case because kyle careu's estranged wife
is a judge in lubbock county an attorney
for kyle karuth told a texas tv station
that his client acted in self-defense to
date no charges have been filed brian
thanks angenet let's bring back criminal
defense attorney bernardo villalona and
terry austin terry carl ruth is claiming
self-defense does this look like
self-defense to you though
brian this does not look like
self-defense to me carruth went back
into the house to get his gun they were
verbally threatening each other but
karuth was really not in any sort of
danger and under texas law he has to
reasonably believe the force was
imminently necessary to protect against
like an unlawful entry there that being
his home but if you look carefully at
that video he had opportunities just to
back away and it did not look like
anyone was threatening him or someone
was going to attack him or go into the
house so i don't think it looks like
self-defense i think it was an argument
that got out of hand and that in fact
carruth was the one who provoked the
entire incident now bernardo we know the
castle doctrine in texas is very strong
but let's throw in one fact to see if
that changes uh anything if red had a
court order to see his child and karuth
was stopping him from seeing his child
does that change anything in terms of
self-defense
i don't think it changes anything in
terms of self-defense because the video
speaks for itself just like terry said
this was no confrontation in terms of
that you fear for imminent death or
serious bodily injury here it just seems
that he wanted to puff up his chest and
show who's the boss so i hope that the
whoever's looking at this can take that
into account the problem we have here is
that you know when it comes to texas
laws and the duty to retreat it kind of
doesn't work in the favor of the
deceased in this case
all right well engine now is there
anything more to this video in this
confrontation
well actually brian there is another
video that the attorney for kyle carruth
has released to a tv station in texas
and it shows the view from the front
porch so you're seeing kind of a reverse
of what we just watched and he says that
backs up the claim of self-defense now
i've reached out to that attorney for a
comment and to request that video
right now though the attorney has not
returned my calls and my emails
all right we'll see
how we get that next video because
that'll be interesting to seeing the
other angle because at least in this
video it appears that when karuth does
shoot at reed that there may be some
distance between the two of them the
question here is is reid advancing on
karuth is he retreating that could also
add into the factors as to whether or
not deadly force should have been used
uh thank you very much for that and it
will hopefully get that video in soon
and we can bring you back into dissect
and of course terry and bernardo always
a pleasure thank you very much
and onto a case that's gripped the
nation from the start we could soon
learn if actor jesse smallette was
actually attacked or if his january 2019
assault was staged to promote his career
jury selection began monday in the trial
of the former empire star smollett
claims he was the victim of an attack
near his chicago apartment nearly three
years ago smallett reported two men put
a noose around his neck and poured an
unknown liquid on him while yelling
racial and homophobic slurs the case was
initially investigated as a hate crime
but police later said the actor paid two
brothers from the tv show he worked on
to stage the attack for publicity two
months later the 39 year old was
indicted on more than a dozen felony
disorderly conduct counts for filing a
false police report those charges were
later dropped last year smallette was
indicted on six other counts relating to
the incident the actor continually
denies he planned the attack somalia's
charges carry a max sentence of three
years in prison a judge ruled no cameras
are being allowed in the courtroom for
the duration of the trial
coming up on law and crime daily we head
to new england where the trial begins
for a man accused of strangling his wife
while his children slept in the other
room plus elizabeth holmes takes a stand
in her own trial as a former
businesswoman defends herself against
nearly a dozen counts of criminal fraud
more on that next
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
after 11 weeks in federal court the jury
finally hears from the defendant
elizabeth holmes last week the former
therino ceo took the stand in her own
defense
monday marked the fourth day of
testimony for holmes who faces 11 counts
of fraud for her time with a now defunct
blood testing company last week holmes
admitted she added pharmaceutical
company logos like pfizer or sharing
plow to theranos's validation reports
she sent out to investors holmes
testified that companies never
authorized theranos to use the logos but
holmes says she used them anyways
because theranos had worked alongside
the companies in the past ahead of
holmes testimony investors told the jury
they believe the pharmaceutical
companies themselves sent over the
paperwork further investor testimony
showed holmes touted a theranos
partnership with the u.s department of
defense some saying holmes told them the
edison device was used in military
helicopters overseas prosecutors say
these claims are false the holmes later
testified military doctors had discussed
the device's use for burn victim
treatment if convicted homes could face
up to 20 years in prison
let's bring brac criminal defense
attorney bernardo vilona and co-host
terry austin terry elizabeth holmes took
the stand to tell her story do you think
that will help our work in her favor
you know brian actually i do think it's
going to help her case oftentimes you
don't want to put your defendant on the
stand but she is naturally very
charismatic she's able to connect with
the members of the jury and she wants to
tell her side of the story
and i think she can explain what her
thought process was during this whole
ordeal she can explain her fears she can
explain her concerns why she made the
decisions that she made and remember
there are five women on this jury and i
think that is going to have an impact
they're going to relate to holmes and
sometimes i think they're going to
understand that women are subjected to
harsher scrutiny so i think all in all
it was a very calculated move to put
elizabeth holmes on the stand but i
actually think it was a good move for
the defense it's an interesting turn in
calculated move because bernard that's
what i want to ask you about what do you
think of the trial strategy by the
defense as to having homes admit to some
of the small wrongs such as the labels
but not to the major wrongs like fraud
exactly so for the defense what they try
to do is that they're minimizing their
loss they're minimizing her exposure so
what they're going to end up arguing
doing closing arguments is like look she
admitted to what she did was wrong she
was honest about her wrongdoings and
because she was honest about those wrong
doings that is what you should probably
find her guilty of but not of the higher
counts or the other counts that she's
denying because she came to you and she
gave you the good the bad and the ugly
it's interesting it's almost like some
defense is where we see defense
attorneys will come out and say yes what
my client did was wrong maybe
questionably wrong maybe morally wrong
and to terry's point there are
more stricter oversight on some people
in the tech community especially
young women but the defense could come
out and say
what she did may have been wrong but not
criminal that would be interesting
closing arguments to hear but of course
federal court we can't bring the cameras
uh or bring you into the court through
the camera so we'll bring the court to
you with our expert legal analysis thank
you again bernarda and terry when we
come back the latest details on the
trial of a man charged in the murder of
his wife opening statements are given in
william argy's new hampshire trial
welcome back to law and crime daily a
jury considers the fate of convicted cop
killer mark heath lloyd on monday lloyd
returned to the courtroom for sentencing
last month a jury found lloyd guilty of
first-degree murder in the shooting
death of orlando police lieutenant debra
clayton lloyd shot and killed clayton
while she was trying to arrest him for
killing his pregnant ex-girlfriend a
month earlier he was already serving
life in prison for his ex-girlfriend's
murder but now faces the death penalty
in the days following the trial the
judge decided the jurors could know that
an officer kicked lloyd in the face
which caused him to lose an eye this
later brought into question orlando
police department's use of force the
same jury that convicted lloyd will now
hear from witnesses on why he should or
should not be sentenced to death the
sentencing process is expected to take
several days
money and hate that's the motive
prosecutors say bill rg had for the 2019
murder of his wife on monday his trial
began prosecutors say the 46 year old
new hampshire man killed his wife
maureen by either strangling or
smothering her she was 39 years old
artie was the only beneficiary of his
wife his wife's 400 000 life insurance
policy prosecutors say rg lost his job
as a physician's assistant and
accumulated mounting debt as gambling as
a gambling addict they say argy asked a
friend to help kill his wife and when he
declined argy asked for help hiring a
hitman authorities say argy killed his
wife then tried to die by suicide after
he threw away his cell phone and gambled
at a casino during opening statements
the defense claimed argie did not kill
his wife but that he found her in bed
with a sheet tied around her neck on the
stand argy's friend told jurors he had
mentioned a plan to kill his wife in the
past
for about how long had the defendant
expressed his satisfaction with his
marriage to mourinho to you about
three four five years
did the defendant also in conversations
with you talk about killing his wife
maureen he did
and about when did those conversations
occur in relation to the intervention in
march of 2018.
it's been a year or two prior to that
what did the defendant say to you in
those conversations that you remember
killing his wife
he
he basically
you know part of the conversation was
all right bill you're going to go down
to you're going to go down to south
maureen's not going to go
she's going to take half of everything
so you're going to make twice as much
money but you're going to write a check
right back to maureen up here
and he didn't want to hear any of that
and with respect to killing his wife
what would he say about that
all right again he said
i'll do it or i'll hire somebody
during cross-examination the same friend
told defense attorneys argy was out of
control and intervention was staged he
later said he checked in with argie's
wife who said everything was okay
what was the primary concern being
talked about for bill
well his gambling his infidelity there's
a variety of his drinking
uh he's out of control
so gambling insults addiction
yeah
and he also at times when he was with
you he threatened to commit suicide
himself
[Music]
yep
when you were at the intervention
did you say anything about his threats
to so-called kill anyone
no this was about helping bill
anything that they they tell you lead
you to believe or how they're acting
lead you to believe that there's
anything wrong
uh
she was uncomfortable she didn't talk
very much at the wedding
she kind of said everything was okay
bernard in a case with so much
circumstantial evidence that argy wanted
his wife dead what fact sticks out to
you the most that helps a prosecution
well aside from this witness who
testified that the husband actually
tried to enlist him to do the killing or
even hire a hitman that sticks out to me
but also what sticks out to me is that
maureen called 9-1-1 just days prior to
make sure that the emergency line was
working just in case
yeah that's uh
i don't mean to laugh but as a defense
attorney i don't know how you get from
underneath that of course we'll keep
watching but terry the defense is
claiming that the suicide attempt and
the gambling are evidence of innocence
not guilt does that make sense to you
brian that makes no sense to me to me a
suicide attempt and most people would
interpret it this way is a sign of
consciousness of guilt and the gambling
to me means that you have no remorse if
you're doing that after the wife has
died so i think the defense is trying to
deal with the facts as they've been
presented to the defense and she's
interpreting these incidents and making
that interpretation work to their
advantage to show that the defendant
really somehow was innocent of all of
this it's really hard to understand how
someone can kill their spouse especially
if the children are in the house but it
seems like it happened it seems like the
facts are stacked against this defendant
and frankly i definitely think that the
defense attorney is doing the best she
can with the facts in this case and
trying to argue that it all points to
innocence and the fact that there's this
financial gain has nothing to do with
anything yeah as a defense attorney if
there are circumstantial facts or
evidence in the case they've got to kind
of bend that to their side as best as
they can but of course we'll keep
following this case and giving you
updates thank you both and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you